so sage nein stimmen morgen hier aus dem
zdf heute live studio in mainz nach
einer spannenden wahl nacht in den usa
die bislang nicht das ergebnis geliefert
hat dass sich viele erhofft haben es
gibt kein eindeutiges ergebnis sondern
steht jetzt stand 7 uhr 31 kopf an kopf
zwischen beiden bewerbern
wir schauen wir auf die zahlen hier
hinter mir auf unserer app und im web
zdf heute.de gibt es nämlich natürlich
alle aktuellen zahlen und wenn ich jetzt
hier mal gucken auf der startseite gibt
es hier eine grafik und da können wir
sehen es steht gerade 210 wahlleute zu
210 war leute also wirklich ein
kopf-an-kopf-rennen wir können uns das
im detail mal angucken wenn wir hier
weiter runter gehen und auf die grafik
klicken us war 2020 ergebnisse in den
bundesstaaten und dort können wir sehen
die roten staaten sind die die für
donald trump mehrheitlich gestimmt haben
die blauen sind die die mehrheitlich für
joe biden gestimmt haben und die gelben
sind die noch nicht ausgezählt sind und
das sind zum beispiel nevada da ist der
auszählungsstand wir können das hier
sehen gerade mal sieben prozent da kann
es noch eine weile dauern bis wir zu
einem ergebnis kommen wir gucken mal
weiter hier zum beispiel wisconsin hat
77% ausgezählt also das ganze kann sich
noch in die länge ziehen das war
prognostiziert und von manchen
befürchtet worden
donald trump hat schon gesagt das will
ja eigentlich nicht so akzeptieren und
die beiden liefern sich jetzt quasi über
die medien schon eine ja ein
schlagabtausch wir sprechen darüber
heute mit unseren korrespondenten alissa
jung in washington und johannes hano in
delaware der dort beim lager der
demokraten ist wo joe biden quasi sein
wahlkampf headquarter aufgebaut hat und
wir schauen mal vor allem jetzt was dort
joe biden heute schon gesagt hat vor
einer knappen dreiviertelstunde
die ergebnisse werden wir morgen für
haben vielleicht dauert es noch ein
bisschen länger
das ist doppelt wichtig bei mir und das
wiegt
liegt bei donald kahn zu sagen wir hier
gewonnen hat das sagt das amerikanische
volk also dass das war donnert joe biden
sorry mit seinem ersten statement donald
trump hat darauf schon reagiert und
darüber nicht sprechen mit unseren
beiden korrespondenten vor ort einmal
alissa jung in washington und johannes
hano in delaware
ich fange mal bei alisa an hat donald
trump darauf schon reagiert und was hat
er gesagt er hat schon darauf reagiert
von einer guten dreiviertelstunde hat er
gibt twittert und zwar folgendes er hat
gesagt wir liegen weit vorn aber sie
versuchen und mit sie mahnt er die
demokraten unsere wahl zu stehlen
wir werden das nicht wir werden das
nicht zulassen und außerdem und das ist
vielleicht der wichtigste punkt stimmen
können nicht mehr nach aber ausgezählt
werden nachdem die die wahl um
geschlossen sind und das ist natürlich
der entscheidende punkt weil
beispielsweise in vielen bundesstaaten
liegt joe biden in der briefwahl klar
vorne oder lang auch immer klar klar
vorne
und das ist jetzt natürlich eine aussage
wenn es heißt es sollen keine stimme
mehr gezählt werden was passiert dann
also mit den ganzen stimmen die über
briefwahl reinkommen wir schalten so
johannes hano in delaware im headquarter
der republikaner
johannes was hat joe biden quasi jetzt
noch gesagt außer dass er damit rechnet
dass es noch länger dauern könnte
man muss ganz klar sagen dass das alles
ja gerade gesagt hat darum ging es ja
bei er wollte als erster hier auftreten
er wollte von anfang an nicht in die
defensive geraten deswegen ist er als
erster aufgetreten hat gesagt solange es
noch eine rechnerische möglichkeit gibt
und die gibt es ja weil noch unzählige
briefwahlstimmen nicht ausgezählt sind
so lange ist der präsident noch nicht
entschieden so lange haben wir keinen
neuen präsidenten die müssen jetzt
ausgezählt werden und hat wohl schon
geahnt dass donald trump das fordern
wird was er dann in seinem tweet ja auch
getan hat den alice ja gerade zitiert
hat also insofern ist das alles seine
strategie gewesen von anfang an seine
kampagne hatte das vorab auch schon
gesagt wenn es eng wird wenn es aber
noch eine chance gibt wird joe biden
alles tun um sozusagen das heft des
handelns in die hand zu nehmen und
donald trump den weg zu verwehren sich
zum präsidenten ausgerufen und es war
klar dass eine niederlage in einem
solchen fall hier
joe biden nicht eingestehen wird und so
ist es dann auch gekommen er hat seine
leute zum aufgerufen durchzuhalten und
hoffnung zu haben
warum ist das so wichtig dass er das
heft des handelns in der hand behält ich
meine die stimmen sind hier als
abgegeben man kann im grunde nur noch
abwarten was als nächstes passiert oder
gerade gesagt er dort trump hat ja wohl
schon angekündigt gerade das also jetzt
nur die stimmen gezählt werden sollen
die heute in der urne waren dh die
briefwahl ergebnisse sollen nicht
ausgezählt werden das hatte im vorfeld
der schon immer gemacht hat im vorfeld
ja schon immer wieder gesagt diese
briefe als sowieso alles nur betrug und
am wahlabend müsste der gewinner
feststehen weil er weiß dass die meisten
briefwahlstimmen oder ein großteil der
briefwahlstimmen er für die demokraten
sind denn das ist klar das haben ja alle
umfragen gezeigt die demokraten haben
mehrheitlich mit also bei der briefwahl
haben mehrheitlich demokraten mit der
briefwahl abgestimmt und er will
natürlich vermeiden dass es jetzt wo es
knapp wird möglicherweise dann doch noch
am ende gegen ihn ausgeht deswegen will
er das unterbinden und genau dagegen ist
joe biden sozusagen heute abend schon
mal in die bresche gesprungen und hat
gesagt nein es wird ausgezählt bis zum
bitteren ende
und das wird jetzt die nächsten tage
heftiges geschrei und gezeter geben hier
zwischen den beiden
hier gibt es gerade schon auf aus
unserer zuschauerschaft auf youtube
fragen warum werden die briefwahlstimmen
nicht zuerst gezählt johannes
also das ist eine sehr komplizierte
frage lässt sich also nur sehr
kompliziert beantworten kann aber um es
mal ganz einfach zu machen jeder
bundesstaat hat seine eigenen regeln in
manchen bundesstaaten wie florida zum
beispiel wurden die schon konnte schon
die ganze zeit nach dem eingang konnten
die geöffnet werden wurde schon gezählt
lagen die also schon fotos wegen war
florida heute auch sehr schnell mit dem
ausziehen
in anderen bundesstaaten ist es das
gesetz das erst ausgezählt werden darf
wenn also am wahltag die geöffnet werden
darf die briefwahl
das kann jetzt noch jetzt müssen die
geöffnet werden da sind millionen briefe
zettel auch noch in wahrscheinlich in
philadelphia und pennsylvania millionen
die müssen dann erst noch gezählt werden
das ist ganz einfach ein bundesstaaten
gesetz also jeder staat macht das anders
und deswegen sind diese drei staaten die
jetzt noch ausstehen penzel wenn ihr
wisst konz in und michigan so wichtig
die können alles nochmal umwerfen
wie ist denn jetzt eigentlich die
stimmung bei euch ich fange nochmal bei
johannes an hintergeht sehr sehr ruhig
aus das ist merkwürdig dass doch
eigentlich sich um ein headquarter der
demokraten handelt naja das war hier die
ganze zeit ruhig glauben hat ja immer
auf open air veranstaltung setzt auf
social distanz die leute kamen hier kurz
bevor er auf die bühne getreten ist
wurden sie per sms informiert hierher zu
kommen die kamen dann mit dem auto und
sind kurz danach jetzt auch schon wieder
alle weg gefahren also hier gibt somit
nichts zu feiern sondern wir es
tatsächlich er auch ein bisschen trübe
stimmung der mann hatte sich hier sehr
viel mehr erwartet man hat ja von der
blue wave geträumt die die umfragen ja
auch alle vorhergesagt haben aber
nachdem joe biden hier gesprochen hat
hat sich alles auch sehr schnell wieder
verdünnisiert um es mal kurz zu sagen
dann schaue ich mal zu alice danach
washington auch bei dir sieht es im
hintergrund eher entspannt aus würde ich
mal sagen wie hast du die letzten
stunden in der hauptstadt erlebt das ist
richtig jetzt hier gerade ihr könnt
hinter mir sehen hier ist das weiße haus
zu sehen und es sind jetzt tatsächlich
weniger menschen hier und es ist
wirklich gerade auch eine entspannte
stimmung
das war im laufe des abends immer wieder
ganz unterschiedlich und zwar ist hier
wirklich also nur ein film klein nur ein
funken genügt teilweise um die stimmung
hier zum zum kochen zu bringen
beispielsweise kleine band aufgetreten
und die polizei wollte dass sie die
straße räumen und dann ist ganz schnell
eine straßenblockade entstanden und dann
kam
mehrere swat teams raus also teams der
polizei und haben diese band umzingelt
und sie dann also zum gehen gezwungen
und eben gerade ist aber dass es auf der
anderen seite mal darzustellen ist eben
gerade ist eine ein protest von
aktivistinnen von black lars metter
durch die stadt gezogen und zwar eine
ganze strecke mehrere mehrere kilometer
und da hat die polizei sie einfach
gewähren lassen also es ist tatsächlich
jetzt bislang durchgängig friedlich
friedlich gewesen aber schon auf jeden
fall auch immer wieder angespannt wenn
ich mal eine prognose unserer beiden
korrespondentinnen in den usa wagen darf
was glaubt ihr wie geht das jetzt aus
mal angefangen bei johannes kannst du
die frage noch mal kurz wiederholt du
bist ja gerade ganz abgehakt angekommen
was glaubst du wie geht diese wahl jetzt
aus wer wird gewinnen magst du eine
prognose
ja ich hab die ganze zeit schon gesagt
dass am ende doch wieder präsident wird
das wollte keiner so richtig wahrhaben
aber wenn man hier durchs land gefahren
ist dann hat man gemerkt dass der
enthusiasmus für joe biden nicht
wirklich groß war
ich glaube es wird sehr sehr eng werden
es wird am ende so eng werden dass
donald trump oder joe biden die gerichte
anrufen wird und dann wird das sich über
wochen mehrere wochen wahrscheinlich
hinziehen am ende wird aber dann donald
trump präsident werden weil er in seiner
amtszeit ich glaube mehr als 200 fälle
jazz also bundesrichter ernannt hat die
auf seiner seite stehen und am ende
werden die gerichte für ihn entscheiden
das ist meine prognose sodann alisa was
meinst du siehst du dich an
ich habe eben gerade auch nur den
letzten teil von johannes antwort
verstanden aber ich würde mich insofern
anschließen dass ich glaube und das
haben ja auch viele hier schon vorher
gesehen dass es eben im knappes rennen
werden könnte und dass es auf jeden fall
in einem in einem streit auch enden
könnte und das zeichnet sich jetzt ganz
klar ab auch durch den tweet von trump
schon dass es also ganz klar dass er
hier sagt ab jetzt sollen quasi keine
briefwählerinnen stimmen mehr ausgezählt
werden
da stehen die zeichen jetzt wirklich
schon auf chaos und streit und ich
glaube darauf können wir uns in den
nächsten tagen einstellen
dann sage ich erst mal danke bis hierhin
führt die einschätzungen an euch bei
disentis versuchen am ende unseres teams
mit ihr zu sprechen aber erstmal
danke für eure einschätzungen und für
die einblicke in diese sehr sehr
spannende nacht in den usa so ich schau
mal hier es gibt es einige kommentare es
gibt hier kommentatoren bei euch die
behaupten es wird schon ganz andere
zahlen geben und mit dem üblichen lügen
presse vorwurf kommen es tut mir leid
dass wir einfach nur die zahlen
veröffentlichen können die offiziell
sind und nicht irgendwelche gerüchte von
daher halten wir uns an dieser
offiziellen zahlen und das ganze wird
sich ja auch die nächsten zeit noch
hinziehen
ich schaue mal in die kommentare ob es
noch etwas anderes gibt hier geht's ein
kommentar von hanna fasanerie das
wahlsystem ist veraltet das wollen wir
uns nachher nochmal angucken mit dem
politikwissenschaftler professor
christian lammert von der fu berlin der
uns das alles noch mal genauer erklären
könnt wenn ihr noch weitere fragen habt
zu diesem doch sehr speziell im
wahlsystem oder wie der ablauf der wahl
bisher zwar könnt ihr sie gerne stellen
wir sammeln sie und versuchen sie das
mal gesammelt zu beantworten
ich würde jetzt einmal schauen dass wir
nochmal ganz dezidiert und im detail uns
die aktuellen zahlen erklären lassen und
zwar von meinem kollegen christian
sievers der ist ein hauptstadtstudio in
berlin und der hat uns das ganze mal
zusammengefasst und texas geht jetzt
ganz aktuell an donald trump und dann
haben wir noch einen zweiten start hat s
little rudi da oben rhode island im
nordosten der usa vier wahlleute nur und
diese vier bar leute gehen an joe biden
und dann haben wir jetzt ganz kurz noch
ein zwischenergebnis das wie folgt
aussieht und das ist ganz interessant
wenn man da unten auf diese leiste guckt
270 braucht man um ins weiße haus zu
kommen beide haben im moment 209 der
absoluten gleichstand soll bei sehr
interessant wenn man sieht woher die
beiden kommen also aus den umfragen der
letzten wochen und auch mit von den
zahlen mit denen wir diese nacht diese
lange wahlen nach heute begonnen haben
da lag die beiden ganz weit vorne und
donald trump war ganz weit hinten
und jetzt haben wir für beide einen
gleichstand 209 209 zurück zeug so da
ist er professor christian lammert in
berlin
herr professor lang hat wir haben hier
ein paar zuschauer die daran zweifeln
dass wir tatsächlich live senden und wir
wurden auf
fordert mal zu denken wenn das
tatsächlich live wäre von tief viel los
das machen wir jetzt mal hallo guten
morgen tatsächlich wir sind live herr
professor lammert sie sind professor für
amerikanische politik und alles was drum
herum passiert
haben sie diesen ablauf kommen sehen
ja man konnte schon kommen sehen wir
haben zwar einige umfragen sehen die die
demokraten und beiden weiter vorne
gesehen haben aber wir wissen in den usa
die letzten 45 präsidentschaftswahlen
waren immer sehr sehr knapp die
gesellschaft ist tief gespalten das ist
fast 50 50 und wir haben eben dieses
komische wahlsystem mit dem wahlen leute
gremium was das wahlergebnis auch noch
ein bisschen verzerren kann und deswegen
war eigentlich damit zu rechnen dass es
knapp wird das jetzt trump zb florida
wie es aussieht gewinnt das ist dann
schon eine kleine überraschung
wie kommt das denn zustand also die
umfragen waren jedoch immer relativ pro
beiden wo es einen ich sag mal ein
vorsprung von fünf bis teilweise sogar
neun prozent gegeben hat jetzt sieht es
wieder anders aus wie passt das zusammen
naja umfragen basieren immer auf
statistischen modellen die mit daten aus
der vergangenheit arbeiten man hat jetzt
schon versucht aus den fehlern von 2016
zu lernen und die modelle anzupassen
aber irgendwie scheinen diese
umfrageinstitute bestimmte dynamiken in
der gesellschaft nicht richtig erfassen
zu können
es passiert natürlich auch viel diese
wahl findet statt in einem jahr wo wir
ein amtsenthebungsverfahren hatten wir
die kurve pandemie haben massive
proteste backlights meter das sind alles
sachen die man in solche modelle nur
schwer integrieren kann und wir sehen
wahrscheinlich auch wieder so ein
phänomen das viele leute sich offen
nicht dazu bekennen dass die tram wählen
dass sie dann wenn sie gefragt werden
auf der straße gar nicht sagen oder
sagen ich wähle für beiden weil der
sozial akzeptierte ist in den medien und
dann können diese verzerrungen zu stande
kommen aber wenn man sich zum beispiel
jetzt die zahlen des papierboot anguckt
das letzte mal als ich jetzt geguckt
habe war beiden hier auch schon wieder
mit über eine million stimmen den
vorsprung
das ist nicht ganz so deutlich wie 2016
wo hillary clinton etwas mit drei
millionen stimmen vorsprung gewonnen
hatte aber es werden noch viele stimmen
ausgezählt
also so weit weg wandern manche unfall
ich bin gerade gebeten worden hätte was
soll das ein bisschen lauter sprechen
könnten weil sie bei mir auch sehr leise
ankommen vielleicht funktioniert das
jetzt haben wir hier genau solche
vorwürfe aus der zuschauerschaft auf
facebook schreibt michael brand wie wir
jetzt das zdf künftig mit offensichtlich
gefälschten umfragen umgehen die
allesamt falsch waren
dann gibt es eine kritische aufarbeitung
zum verbreiten offenbar gefälschte
zahlen da müssen wir einfach sagen
lieber herr brandt das hat mit falschen
nichts zu tun
wir haben gerade von professor lammert
gehört dass umfragen und tatsächlich
dann das wahlergebnis teilweise
auseinander gehen aus vielen
verschiedenen gründen die er gerade
erklärt hat hängt es nicht aber auch mit
diesem ball männer system zusammen also
letztes mal war es ja so hillary clinton
hatte eigentlich rein nominell drei
millionen stimmen mehr
trotzdem hat sie verloren können sie das
noch mal erklären warum das überhaupt
stattfinden kann das ist ja für uns
deutsche die wirklich sagen okay eine
stimme ist genauso viel wert wie die wie
die andere ein bisschen merkwürdiges
system also das ist in den usa wenn man
das versucht sich zu verbildlichen nicht
eine wahl die wir sehen sondern
eigentlich 51 nämlich 50 waren in allen
bundesstaaten wo der in den allermeisten
fällen der oder die kandidaten mit den
meisten stimmen alle wahlmänner
frauenstimmen bekommt das heißt man muss
wahlkampf in allen 50 bundesstaaten
führen und kann da gewinnen und
verlieren und dann rechnet man zusammen
wie viel man in diesen einzelnen
bundesstaaten gewonnen hat und das
addiert sich dann zu dieser magischen
zahl zusammen 270 die man braucht und
dass es dann die 51
und deswegen kann es abweichen das
popular bot also die abgegebenen stimmen
vom elektro college road also den
wahlleuten stimmen die die einzelnen
kandidaten haben und wir haben das jetzt
schon 2000 gesehen wo alkohol mehr
stimmen hatte als george hw bush beim
computer wird aber nicht bei den
wahlmänner und frauen und auch 2016
und es deutet sich an dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit besteht dass es
dieses jahr wieder so sein könnte
können sie mal kurz erklären wie diese
gewicht und zustande kommt also da ist
ja gibt es ja pro bundesland gibt es
wahlleute mal 13 mal sind es bis zu 55
wird dass jedes mal neu gerechnet je
nachdem wie viele menschen in diesem
bundesland vor der bundesstadt leben
oder ist es quasi in stein gemeißelt und
ist seit 200 jahren die gleiche anzahl
nein das passt sich schon bisher in an
weil die anzahl der wahl leute die ein
bundesstaat hat setzt sich zusammen aus
den abgeordneten die die bundesstaaten
ins abgeordnetenhaus senden plus den
senatoren und da haben wir diese
verzerrung weil ich den usa egal welcher
bundesstaat ist ist ob es kalifornien
ist oder montana beide schicken zwei
senatoren nach washington und dann
werden auch nur zwei wahlmänner oder
wahlfrauen stimmen eben hier gerechnet
und das führt dann dazu dass wir
eigentlich eine überproportionale
bedeutung kleinerer staaten haben also
das ist gar nicht so wichtig natürlich
hat kalifornien mehr stimmen wahl mehr
stimmen als montana aber gerechnet auf
die bevölkerungszahl hat montana aber
eine höhere bedeutung das kommt momentan
den republikanern sehr zugute weil sie
insbesondere in den kleineren ländlichen
staaten sehr sehr stark sind und hier
durch die bank dann immer alle
wahlmänner stimmen bekommen und die
demokraten hier ein defizit eigentlich
haben strukturelles was 5 bis 6
prozentpunkte ausmacht und das haben wir
auch in vielen umfragen vor der wahl
gesehen dass beiden mindestens sechs
prozentpunkte mehr stimmen haben muss um
überhaupt eine chance zu haben diese
wahlmänner mehrheit zu haben
wenn das darunter ist sind seine
wahlchancen sehr sehr gering und danach
sieht es momentan aus sie schaut bitte
auf meinen rechner hier habe ich ein
kommentar von bta nickname auf youtube
die oder der schreibt ich verstehe nicht
wie dieses wahlmänner system
demokratisch sein kann wenn die
beliebtheit der bevölkerung so anders
ist gibt es da überhaupt keine
auseinandersetzung professor damals
wo sich wo man jemand fragt ob das geht
so nicht mehr
also es wird heftig diskutiert das
problem ist dass das paar männer gremium
in der verfassung festgeschrieben ist
das heißt man braucht eine
verfassungsänderung und dafür brauchen
sie große mehrheiten im kongress und sie
brauchen auch eine sehr große anzahl von
bundesstaaten nämlich drei viertel die
einer solchen änderung zustimmen
und in dieser polarisierten situation
momentan in den usa kriegen sie im
kongress nicht solche mehrheiten
zustande und auch die kleineren
bundesstaaten die ja in der überzahl
sind kein interesse dass dieses system
reformiert wird weil sie dann belanglos
werden wenn man das nach dem putsch oder
wohnt organisieren würde würde wahlkampf
nur noch in kalifornien und new york
stattfinden weil ja die meisten leute
wohnen deswegen ist es unheimlich
schwierig hier eine reform umzusetzen es
gibt auch versuche dass man versucht
dieses winner takes all system in den
staaten zu verändern dass man die wahl
mit einer eben proportional zum
stimmenanteil verteilen wird da gibt es
eine initiative dass die bundesstaaten
das freiwillig machen sollen aber auch
hier kriegt man keine kritische masse
zusammen dass das effekt hätte also die
institutionellen reformen hürden sind
hier so hoch dass die usa mit diesem
archaischen institut noch in der zukunft
weiterleben muss so die schau mal wir
haben hier aktuelle ergebnisse wenn wir
noch mal hier auf unseren monitor
schalten liebe regie dann können wir
hier sehen aktuell auf zdf heute sind
unsere zahlen 203 zehn wahlmänner für
donald trump und 220 für joe biden hat
sich also wieder was getan aber es wird
noch ziemlich lange dauern
wahrscheinlich bis zum beispiel
pennsylvania ausgezahlt ausgezählt ist
da gibt es jetzt hier auch bei uns in
den kommentaren vorwürfe dass wir gerade
zeuge würden werden von wahlfälschung in
pennsylvania das hat auch nochmal
michael brand der sich ja irgendwie
gerade auch schon mal sehr skeptisch
geäußert hat geschrieben gibt es darauf
irgendwelche hinweise dass das dort
wahlfälschungen gibt professor lammert
nein gibt es überhaupt nicht es gibt
immer wieder unregelmäßigkeiten die aber
auf
völlig amateurhaften wahlsystem in den
usa gründen
es gibt keinerlei empirische beweise
dafür in der vergangenheit und auch
jetzt bei den wahlen dass es
wahlmanipulation oder wahlbetrug gegeben
hat das problem ist eben in pennsylvania
her dass es der stadt wo jetzt am
meisten diskutiert wird die haben
gesetzlich festgeschrieben dass sie die
briefwahl lagen erst ausziehen und
öffnen wenn die wahllokale geschlossen
sind das heißt man ist jetzt viel
schneller mit dem auszählen der stimmen
die am wahltag abgegeben worden sind
weil man das mit maschinen machen kann
aber man muss jetzt zum teil manuell
diese wahl briefwahlunterlagen öffnen
und das kann noch zwei tage dauern bis
man dadurch ist und man hat umfragen
gesehen dass die demokraten diese
möglichkeit der briefwahl oder hysterie
votings mehr in anspruch genommen haben
als die republikanischen wähler in
manchen staaten soll das in bis zu 70
oder sogar 80 prozent für demokraten
sein und das wird das resultat noch mal
verändern und deswegen rufen die
demokraten ja momentan zu geduld auf
weil wenn man in einer demokratie lebt
sollten natürlich alle stimmen gezählt
werden und wenn man die möglichkeit hat
eine briefwahl
dann sollte diese stimme auch
rechtzeitig nach den gängigen
rechtlichen grundlagen damit würde er
den rechtspolitischen grund der
amerikanischen demokratie verlassen
herne hat wir hatten gerade ein bisschen
tonprobleme steckt ihr mikrofon richtig
drin im laptop können sie das mal ganz
kurz überprüfen für uns weil es endlich
sind sie gerade wieder ausgefallen wir
hoffen dass es sich regelt hier gibt es
jetzt einen kritischen kommentar von
frank diedrichs auf facebook der meint
auch linke präsidenten wurden durch
dieses wahlsystem gewählt jetzt auf
einmal ist es korrupt lieber frank
diedrichs wir haben von korrupt
überhaupt nicht gesprochen wir haben vor
darüber diskutiert ob das system
demokratisch ist wenn manche stimmen
einfach ja nominell weniger wert sind
als andere
stimmt das denn also es geht davon aus
so richtig ist herr professor lammert
das auch linke präsident würde ich nicht
sagen demokratische präsidenten durch
dieses system gewählt worden sind
aber ich glaube es gab da ja vor allem
in diesen wahlbezirken
verschiebungen wo die jeweiligen an der
regierung sein den parteien versucht
haben die so zu schneidern dass es in
ihre also für sie vorteilhaft ist können
sie das nochmal genauer erklären wie das
funktioniert ja das ist vor allem
relevant für die kongresswahlen das ist
das sogenannte jarrett mentoring dass
man die wahlkreise alle zehn jahre wenn
es den nord sensors gibt neu zuschneiden
kann dass wir nach möglichst
repräsentative verteilung der wahlkreise
nach bevölkerungsdichte haben das ist
glaube ich auch ein konstruktionsfehler
in den usa und hier würde ich nicht
sagen dass das republikanisch oder
demokratisch motiviert aus einer
parteipolitischen perspektive sondern
das oblag den regierungen in den
einzelstaaten und das sind dann sind sie
leider gerade die daten mehr sich
ausgefallen das ist schade weil das
glaube ich sehr interessant war
jetzt sind sie ich höre jetzt gerade gar
nicht mehr der ist auch nicht jetzt geht
es wieder
jetzt zeigt er immer alles funktionieren
ok naja das ist halt so mit der technik
und diese im internet und manchmal
fummelt manchmal nicht so richtig also
ich sehe jetzt hier vor allem kritische
kommentare aber das ist halt relativ
normal dass die menschen die sich für
donald trump aussprechen relativ
lautstark immer in den kommentaren sind
ich schaue noch mal ob wir hier fragen
an sie haben professor amazon
wahlbeteiligung gibt es fragen wie hoch
die war das können wir glaube ich noch
nicht sagen weil noch nicht alle stimmen
ausgezählt sind
ja aber es deutet zum vergleich
nur 56 prozent also ist sie zu hause als
würde die wahlbeteiligung deutlich hoch
gehen ich hoffe man kann mich hören
professor lama dafür leider
schwierigkeit mit dem ton haben die wir
jetzt gerade nicht beheben können auch
nicht wissen woran es liegt
wir schauen noch mal ob es irgendetwas
gibt dennis toningenieure gibt in diesem
internet stream die da eingreifen können
und schnell zu professor noch mal fahren
könnten er ist super aber ich weiß auch
nicht also hat es eigentlich ganz gut
mit seiner skype schalter ist es
manchmal halt schwierig ich sehe hier
gerade keine dringenden fragen mehr an
sie deswegen würde ich mich erst mal bei
ihnen bedanken für diese antworten und
für ihre zeit heute morgen und wir
checken das vielleicht später noch
einmal woran das gelegen haben könnte
wir lernen ja auch alle immer noch dazu
dass gerade diese technik ist wo wir
einfach sagen das muss einfach sagen wir
haben kein kamerateam zum professional
geschickt sondern er hat das selber
aufgebaut mit seinem laptop das spart
natürlich zeit das spart geld aber
manchmal geht es dann auch wieder
so ist es dann ja deswegen vielen dank
professor lammert nach berlin für diese
einschätzung und für diese einblicke
über das amerikanische wahlsystem und
ich schaue es nochmal auf die zahlen da
hat sich noch nichts verändert es ist
weiterhin so 213 wahlmänner stimmen für
donald trump 220 für joe biden
ich würde noch mal gucken haben wir noch
eine leitung zu alisa in washington
steht die noch da ist sie alisa hast du
gerade zu hören können was professor
lampert gesagt hat oder ist es bei dir
nicht angekommen du bist ja viel
unterwegs
wir warten erstmal ganz tollen tor super
alles hören können ja also auch da
möchte noch mal kurz sagen weil wir
hatten gestern ein paar tonprobleme auch
alisa ist einfach als one woman show
unterwegs ja ein eine handy eine
mobilfunk-verbindung und das war es kein
kamerateam und deswegen wenn es mal
schwierigkeiten gibt ist da einfach
keiner hinter der kamera der eingreifen
kann sondern sie macht das ganz alleine
und das finde ich ziemlich toll du hast
gar dazu gehört es gibt die diskussion
über das wahlmänner system über das
wahlsystem in den usa
du bist durch die usa gefahren in den
letzten monaten und wochen und hast
viele stimmen gesammelt
wie hast du die stimmung wahrgenommen
gibt es viele menschen die damit
unzufrieden sind oder gibt es auch leute
die sagen ja das alles total tipptopp
super das muss so bleiben
es gibt tatsächlich viele so jetzt haben
wir gar ein kleines regie problem und
nochmal alles wir müssen auch mal vorne
anfangen und sind gerade gesprungen
im bild gar kein problem gar kein
problem und zwar ja und zwar sind das
tatsächlich ist dass die meinung von
vielen menschen hier im land und zwar
auf beiden seiten des parteienspektrums
also das haben beide immer wieder von
dieser wahlnacht jetzt quasi gesagt dass
sie das system ungerecht und unfair
finden weil eben am ende nicht der
wählerinnen wille im zweifel zählt
sondern eben das sogenannte electronic
also die wahlleute
und das haben jetzt im vorfeld der wahl
als noch keiner wusste wie es ausgehen
wird also wirklich beide seiten immer
wieder auch als vielleicht ein bisschen
überholt empfunden und denn jetzt ist
natürlich haben wir die situation die
eben alle befürchtet haben es könnte
hier tatsächlich auf ein
kopf-an-kopf-rennen herauslaufen und
jetzt ist wirklich in den nächsten tagen
vermute ich mal wenn wir jetzt also
tatsächlich hier rausgehen uns nicht
ganz genau klar ist jetzt hier gewonnen
könnte es also wirklich sein dass wir
uns hier auf eine tagelange
berichterstattung einstellen müssen
so jetzt gibt es hier stimmen die
schmiede behaupten das würde andere
zahlen geben donald trump hätte schon
längst die 270 stimmen gewonnen ich habe
jetzt gerade mal geguckt wer sich nicht
auf uns verlassen möchte man kann zum
beispiel bei cnn nachgucken
ich schaue mal auf unseren rechner bitte
hier in der regie da steht es laut cnn
220 zu 213 dass wir da unten kann man
sehen
das ist quasi identisch zu unseren
zahlen wenn wir zu fox news gehen da
gibt es ganz unten ein reiter ich
versuche immer größer zu machen
da nicht für all die sachen tour in
beiden 238 trump 213 also foxnews fox
news hat sogar noch zahlen die mehr pro
beiden sind alisa kannst du uns erklären
wie es dazu kommt dass es gerade dann
doch so unterschiedliche zahlen
teilweise gibt
das hat auch ehrlicherweise ein bisschen
mit der medienlandschaft hier zu tun
also es gibt natürlich oder auch sowieso
mit jetzt sehr vielen social media
plattformen wo auch jeder natürlich
etwas dazu kostet und es gibt hier in
der medienlandschaft auf jeden fall
schon auch immer ein bisschen eine eine
richtung wie vielleicht ihr berichtet
wird so gilt fox news als der
konservative sender der im zweifel jetzt
natürlich er in den letzten jahren
zumindest in die richtung von einigen
republikanern berichtet hat und so gibt
es beispielsweise natürlich auch genauso
medienhäuser die er in richtung der
demokraten berichtet haben also das ist
hier ein punkt aber was wirklich ganz
ganz wichtig ist es tatsächlich also
solange noch gezählt wird und vor allem
in diesem jahr in diesem jahr wo so
viele menschen aus angst während der
korona pandemie per brief gewählt haben
sollte man noch warten bis wirklich alle
stimmen ausgezählt sind bevor irgendeine
seite und sei es ein medienhaus oder
auch der präsident selbst also sich hier
irgendjemand tatsächlich weit vorne
sieht wenn nicht alle stimmen ausgezählt
sind und es kommen ja wirklich noch
einige auch in den nächsten tagen noch
dazu weil in manchen bundesstaaten zählt
tatsächlich der poststempel also alles
was heute abgestempelt wurde
das wird auch noch beispielsweise in
virginia bis am freitag noch ausgezählt
ich habe hier auch nochmal kritische
stimmen aus der zuschauerschaft von
icici adami waren es nicht die ganzen
experten ins zdf die beiden schon als
wahlsieger ausmachten und sogar von
einem erdrutschsieg sprachen da kann ich
nur noch mal wiederholen wir haben uns
natürlich weitgehend auf umfragen
verlassen wir haben aber auch gerade
gehört natürlich umfragen sind nicht
immer verlässlich weil menschen nicht
immer die antworten geben die sie
tatsächlich ehrlich meinen sondern
teilweise eine sogenannte sozial
erwünschte antwort geben weil sie wissen
dass für donald trump zustimmen manchmal
nicht richtig gut ankommt dann ist eben
das problem mit den wahlmännern wir
haben gerade gehört von professor
lammert politikprofessor an der fau
berlin für amerikanistik der sagte 6
prozent ungefähr muss beiden führen
damit er überhaupt genug wahlleute
zusammenbekommt da hängt ja immer an
diesen swing states allerdings hast du
auch in diesem zwings unterwegs
ich war unter anderem auch in ein paar
swing states unterwegs beispielsweise in
wisconsin oder auch in ohio und auch ein
paar die jetzt wie jetzt quasi als so
genanntes swing states galt
beispielsweise arizona arizona wäre
nämlich auch die frage wieder abgestimmt
wir da gewählt wird es gibt eine große
latino population also da ist die frage
wie die wellen und in den swing states
selber ist tatsächlich es sind bisschen
unterschiedlicher gewesen vom
meinungsbild als jetzt in klassisch
republikanischen oder demokratischen
staaten also das stimmt schon und
deswegen sind ja auch so spannend und
alle blicken jetzt noch in den nächsten
stunden vielleicht aber auch tagen eben
auf genau diese sogenannten swing states
also wo eben ist nicht klar ist dass sie
jetzt einheitlich wählen werden in einem
also in einem jahr immer gleich sondern
die wählen mal so und mal so
die bürgerinnen da haben
unterschiedliche bedürfnisse und je
nachdem wer da mit einem parteiprogramm
auftritt was vielleicht auch gutes für
den swing state entscheidet sich dann in
dem jahr die wahl
du hast gerade arizona angesprochen wir
schauen wir auf unser wahl tool auf
unserer seite
und wenn wir da noch mal auf den anderen
bildschirm schalten dann können wir hier
sehen
arizona hat nach unseren informationen
gerade einem auszählungsstand von 80
prozent und dort steht es 46,3 prozent
für donald trump und 52,4 prozent für
joe biden wahlleute kann ich hier gerade
nicht sehen wie viele dort waren weißt
du dass zufällig aus dem kopf an dieser
wie viele wahlleute in arizona zur wahl
gehen werden dann jetzt forderst du mich
hier raus aus dem kopf es ist nicht ich
müsste es genauso nachgucken wie du das
wäre auch ein bisschen gemein dadurch
versuchen
nein das brauchen wir nicht also das
interessante ist halt dass das
tatsächlich weiterhin ausgezählt wird
das dass wir warten darauf dass donald
trump vor die presse tritt es gab eine
information dass es sich gleich äußern
wird er hat ja schon getwittert und wenn
wir uns diesen tweet mal angucken auch
noch mal auf meinem rechner
dann können wir sehen dass twitter den
wieder markiert hat auf deutsch steht
dort einige oder alle inhalte die in
diesem tweet geteilt werden sind
umstritten oder möglicherweise
irreführend den bezug auf die
beteiligung an einer wahl oder an einem
ihren staatsbürgerlichen prozess also
dort hat twitter diesen tweet von donald
trump wo er sagt dass die demokraten
versuchen die wahl zu stehlen mit einem
warnhinweis versehen das ist ja auch
eine etwas neue entwicklung dass die
sozialen netzwerke tatsächlich anfangen
diese äußerungen der verschiedenen
politischen parteien entweder auch zu
bremsen oder mit gewissen hinweisen zu
versehen was mich noch mal interessiert
an dieser wenn wir zu den swing states
kommt gibt es in der erklärung dafür
warum die nicht eindeutig zuzuordnen
sind
es ist tatsächlich so dass es da jetzt
schon also wenn wir jetzt mal über die
sogenannten swing states sprechen die
jetzt im mittleren westen liegen also
die 2016 ganz knapp an donald trump
gingen die ihm aber letztendlich den
sieg beschert haben also da ist es
einfach war es die wirtschaftliche
situation die manche staaten dazu
gebracht hat sich sie sich immer wieder
auch zu verändern weil beispielsweise im
sogenannten rostgürtel also rosberg lag
eben die schwerindustrie die
autoindustrie und das sind viele
arbeitsplätze weggebrochen mit den
jahrzehnten also denen ging es lange gut
und dann plötzlich ging es ihnen sehr
sehr schlecht und 2016 hat donald trump
eben vielen menschen in diesem
sogenannten raesfeld versprochen ich
bring euch arbeitsplätze ich war also
ich mach euer leben besser und ich
kümmere mich um euch und daran haben
viele geglaubt und das war eben in punkt
2016 tm da ganz viele stimmen gebracht
hat und das war einfach wann also
starten
denen ging es mal gut und dann ging es
ihnen aber schlechter und dann natürlich
wenn die menschen sehr verzweifelt sind
dann bleibt es vielleicht auch nicht bei
der meinung und bei der haltung die man
jetzt lange jahre hatte
so jetzt haben wir noch mal lustigen
kommentar von elli himmelblaue auf
facebook die mainzerin ende als
verlässliche quelle anzugeben hätte
ihren tag gemacht ich hätte gern noch
mal auf meinen rechner uni berlin und
dort sehen wir dann nämlich dass hier
unten ganz unten quasi neben meinem bild
sogar fox news gerade beiden nach vorne
sieht mit 238 mal jemand mal wenn dann
zu 213 bzw auch zwei frauen von daher
wir gucken uns schon verschiedene
quellen an und vergleichen die und wir
sehen aber auch dass unterschiedliche
zahlen einfach gibt ich habe auch gehört
als ich jetzt heute morgen dass das
wissen wer florida ist dann donald trump
gegangen und das dort besonders zu den
kinos für ihn gestimmt haben sollen
das wird jetzt als beleg dafür angeführt
dass er nicht rassistisch sein kann dann
ist würden latinos ihn nicht wählen
kennst du die gründe dafür warum latinos
einen präsidenten wählen der gerade was
lateinamerika angeht und was immigranten
aus lateinamerika angeht sicher doch ich
würde sagen teilweise eindeutig
rassistisch geäußert hat ich glaube da
gibt es also wirklich unterschiedliche
gründe führen man kann es vielleicht
auch nicht so einheitlich sagen also
beispielsweise in arizona sieht man
nämlich so hieß ist jetzt die ganze zeit
in den prognosen zumindest das eben dort
die latinos wahrscheinlich sehr
mehrheitlich für die demokraten stimmen
sollen aber jetzt eben darum dass in
florida der fall ist also es zeigt sich
einfach nur da gibt es wirklich sehr
sehr unterschiedliche meinungen auch
natürlich man kann auch nicht da jeden
über über einen kamm scheren natürlich
und es war aber zumindest die mit denen
ich gesprochen habe war schon auch immer
wieder jetzt thema was bei vielen
gepunktet hat tatsächlich war also die
sogenannte law and order politik von
donald trump also er hat versprochen er
bringt sicherheit er bringt ordnung auf
die straßen
und ich hatte hier in washington dc
beispielsweise mit einigen frauen
gesprochen die jetzt in eher unsicheren
nachbarschaften leben und die
tatsächlich sich nach ruhe und
sicherheit in ihrem leben sehen und die
mir dann ehrlicherweise oft kamera
erzählt haben dass sie ihnen vielleicht
menschlich nicht besonders toll finden
werden schon angesprochen da gibt es
also immer wieder stimmen die tramps
menschlich schwierig finden aber die
gesagt haben in dem falle sie glauben an
seine recht und ordnung politik so wenn
ich mal bei uns in die kommentare cook
oder geht es mal wieder hoch her noch
ressourcen moderat ich möchte euch aber
weiterhin dazu auffordern wie jedes mal
bei diesen schwierigen themen doch bitte
sachlich zu bleiben und sich nicht
gegenseitig zu beleidigen weil dann
gehen wir erstens gegen diese kommentare
vor auch gegen die nutzerinnen und
nutzer und müssen irgendwann wenn es zu
viel wird den chat schließen jetzt gibt
es hier einen hinweis an ich solle mich
nicht rollen lassen das ist lieb gemeint
vielen dank tun wir nicht aber wir gehen
natürlich auf die kritischen kommentare
aus der zuschauerschaft ein weil dafür
ist dieses live stream format ja da dass
wir auch mit euch reden mit
und eure relativ beck mit einbauen eure
fragen beantworten können und dann gucke
ich jetzt noch mal wir darauf warten ob
oder wann donald trump vor die presse
tritt
anfragen gibt es noch eine frage ist von
macarena auf youtube wie viele wochen
könnte es maximal dauern bis alle
stimmen ausgezählt sind allerdings da
kannst du das beantworten
es gibt nicht unbedingt jetzt die das
eine datum wo man sagen kann so lange
dauert es bis die stimmen ausgezählt
sind weil das kommt ja auch so viele
verschiedene faktoren also in den 50
bundesstaaten sind ja tatsächlich also
die die die polling stations sehr
unterschiedlich ausgestattet gewesen mit
personal also das kann man nicht sagen
aber was man sagen kann es gibt also
einen gewissen zeitraum und der liegt
anfang mitte dezember
da müssen die sogenannten wahlleute eben
also die diese wahlmänner und -frauen da
müssen die feststehen also diesen
zeitraum gibt es und das sollte man also
möglichst natürlich eingehalten werden
wobei auch es gab jetzt hier immer
wieder diskussionen über die szenarien
was wäre wenn das eintritt was wäre wenn
das nicht eintritt also es gibt da
wirklich verschiedene szenarien wie das
ganze jetzt ausgehen könnte wenn es denn
sehr knapp endet und im zweifel
vielleicht beide parteien sich weigern
das ergebnis anzuerkennen
so jetzt gibt es hier nochmal 2
kommentare zu meiner frage mit den
latinos quasi erklärungen aus unserer
zuschauerschaft einmal hier von levi
live viele kommen aus sozialistischen
ländern und sie schätzen ist das jump
gegen sozialismus wettert und einen
ähnlichen kommentar habe ich hier auf
facebook von susi baric die schreibt
exil-kubaner mögen halt keinen
kommunismus das ist einmal ganz spannend
liest was hat es mit diesem sozialismus
und diesen kommunismus vorwurf immer auf
sich denn ich joe biden richtig
verstanden und auch eingeschätzt habe
nach allem was er so gesagt hat ist er
doch nicht wirklich ein kommunist und
ein sozialist ist ja auch nicht das wäre
ja eher bernie sanders der für sehr viel
verallgemeinerungen und und viel mehr
sozialstaat geworben hat joe biden
bewegt sich doch nicht in diese richtung
oder du sagst es das ist nämlich
tatsächlich das interessante hier also
der tatsächlich progressive
linke-kandidat bernie sanders der ist es
ja am ende gar nicht geworden sondern
joe biden der kandidat aus der mitte der
eher konservative unter den demokraten
geworden
und dann ist es wirklich also ein
narrativ was da entwickelt wurde was
auch von präsident trump und seinen
anhängerinnen natürlich immer weiter
geschärft wurde also die demokraten in
eine sozialistische ecke zu stellen und
das ist wirklich also sehr sehr ist es
ja fast zum schmunzeln weil also
sozialistisch und besonders links und
progressiv ist tatsächlich die politik
von joe biden nicht das wäre bernie
sanders gewesen aber der ist ja
schließlich nicht kandidat geworden
so jetzt geht es auch wieder kommentare
hier werden eindeutig für eine der
beiden optionen ich glaube das können
wir ablehnen wir sind jetzt nicht
eindeutig für eine der beiden optionen
wird gucken einfach kritisch auf beide
seiten und man muss einfach sagen donald
trump bietet wenn man als journalist
sich diese wahl angucken auf den letzten
vier jahre doch relativ viel
angriffsfläche mit dem was er gesagt und
was er getan hat deswegen gibt es auch
relativ viel kritik immer in den medien
er macht es uns einfach muss man sagen
relativ einfach mit allem was er getan
hat so wir warten weiterhin darauf dass
er vor die presse tritt und sich mal
äußerte wahlbeteiligung die frage gab es
ja schon öfter die haben wir schon
versucht zu beantworten wenn wir mal
aufs politische system gucken alisa das
ist ja doch ein bisschen anders als in
den usa was heute als in deutschland
was ja heute auch noch gewählt wurde ist
das repräsentantenhaus und der us-senat
die beiden kann man bilden jahr zusammen
quasi gemeinsam den kongress und dann
gibt es noch den präsidenten jetzt gehen
wir mal quasi ins politik seminar für
anfänger eine us amerikanische politik
kannst du mal versuchen zu erklären wie
die zusammenspielen und warum es wichtig
ist wer in diesen beiden häusern jeweils
die mehrheit hat
ich fand eigentlich dass der professor
lammert ich meine er hat es vorhin auch
angesprochen was sehr interessantes
gesagt hat also der senat das ist
nämlich der dass der fall so der besteht
eben aus jeweils zwei menschen die
entsandt werden in den senat aus den
unterschiedlichen bundesstaaten und das
gibt dem ganzen ein bisschen eine
unwucht also dadurch ist der senat
tatsächlich da sind die kleinen staaten
überrepräsentiert was macht das system
ein bisschen schräg wohingegen im
repräsentantenhaus das spiegelt sich
dann tatsächlich also der wählerin
willem er wieder und die beiden
regulieren sich ich muss euch mal ganz
kurz was sagen ich hab fast kein akku
mehr falls ich gleich weg bin ich wir
sprechen hier mit dem handy zusammen ich
habe es nur schon mal dann angesprochen
gefühlt das war kurz vorneweg das hat
mir das smartphone gerade angezeigt aber
gut entschuldigung ich wollte die frage
noch richtig zu ende beantworten also
die beiden im prinzip kontrollieren die
regierung senat und repräsentantenhaus
und bilden zusammen den kongress und
sind vergleichbar mit bundesrat und
bundestag in deutschland also quasi der
das repräsentantenhaus als bundestag und
der senat als bundesrat
so kann man es wahrscheinlich auf jeden
fall
zusammenfassend jetzt hier in einer sehr
knappen zeit die wir miteinander
verbringen
okay wir hoffen dass das handy gleich
nicht aus ist wir schauen einmal auf das
bild was wir bekommen aus washington
quasi nebenan bei die rallyes hat denn
es gibt hier bereits ein leeres pult mit
vielen flaggen im hintergrund und einem
rednerpult das heißt es wird nicht mehr
lange dauern bis der bisherige us
präsident donald trump vor die presse
tritt
ob er es bleibt wird ist derzeit völlig
ungewiss die wahlmänner und wahlfrauen
stimmen werden ja noch weiterhin
ausgezählt und wenn wir da noch mal auf
die zahlen gucken dann kann ich euch
folgendes sagen bei uns auf der seite
sieht das ganze gerade ordentlich ich
muss mal runter scrollen so aus wir
schauen wir hier auf meinem bildschirm
für jump und 220 stimmen für joe biden
und ich gehe noch mal zu den kollegen
von cnn
bei cnn ist dass ähnliche bild wenn ihr
einmal okay die kollegen haben jetzt ein
bild geändert dann können wir noch mal
reingucken also hier 213 zu 220 hamas da
kann man es sehen und dann jetzt auf
meinen rechner schalten da habe ich die
beiden anderen seiten aufgerufen
cnn sieht auch joe biden vorne mit
sieben wahlleuten 220 zu 213 das ist 1
stand 2 uhr 14 ortszeit das ihn an der
ostküste sitzt sind es - sechs stunden
hast also genau also vor einer minute
geupdatet und wir schauen wie fox news
einen tab weiter
ich mache noch mal einen refresh ob es
etwas neues gibt
wir sehen weiterhin joe biden mit 238
wahl männerstimmen vor neben gegensatz
zu donald trump so samuelsson sagt jetzt
wir sollen alle seine power bank
schenken damit sie weiterhin senden kann
also hast du die zufällig dann kannst du
kurz anschließen oder ist sie auch schon
alle weil du bist ja schon ein paar
stunden unterwegs
das ist richtig ich bin seit fast
fünfzehn stunden unterwegs die sache ist
die dass wenn ich jetzt die power bank
an schließe ich bin ton raus 10 muss ich
spreche hier mit euch über eine
funkstrecke und die steckt dann im
telefon im drin was also vor mir steht
auf einem stativ und wenn ich meinen ton
mir aus könnt ihr mich nicht mehr hören
aber ich könnte dafür laden aber ich
habe den eindruck vielleicht schaffen
wir es noch und ansonsten hört er dann
gleich donald trump aber wir versuchen
es einfach lassen uns weiter miteinander
sprechen was vielleicht auch noch ganz
spannend ist was ich hier euch von vor
ort noch berichten kann es das hier also
verschiedene leute angekündigt haben
schon dass sie morgen auf jeden fall
hier wieder auf die straße gehen wollen
also jetzt gerade ist es ja tatsächlich
hinter mir eher ruhig und nicht so viel
los aber online haben eben ganz viele
sich schon angekündigt morgen auf die
straße zu gehen und wer übrigens auch
hier in dc in der stadt ist sind die
sogenannten braut boys haben sie ja
vielleicht noch im hinterkopf das war
also die die
die gruppe die bei protesten hier in
teilweise gewaltbereit aufgetreten ist
und von der sich donald trump nicht so
richtig distanzieren wollte in der
landes gibt jetzt gibt dir lustige
kommentare auf youtube all dieser wir
müssen uns unsere technische ausrüstung
unterhalten scheinbar das interessiert
vor allem youtube die sich jetzt über
das mobile endgerät aus der
obstabteilung lustig machen das eben
einen speziellen stecker unten hat wo
man nicht einfach noch mal was anstecken
kann ist noch mal überdacht adapter
reden glaube ich und dann gibt es hier
das problem hatten wir gestern den
kommentar warum nimmst du nicht einfach
funkkopfhörer bluetooth kopfhörer
die stören sich mit der funkstrecke so
jetzt wisst ihr mal was unsere
reporterin den ganzen tag machen muss
nicht sich mit elektrotechnik rumärgern
wären sie eigentlich berichten soll aber
das ist halt jetzt mittlerweile auch
unser job wir sind ja sehr dankbar dass
du das alles alleine macht da in der
nacht es gibt eine spannende frage hier
auf facebook von wurden
delikat mehr fragt bestehen nämlich auch
spaltungen innerhalb der demokraten
allein die wahl des kandidaten hat
gezeigt dass auch die demokraten viele
verschiedene meinungen haben da ist doch
donald mit den republikanern ein
stimmiger kann man das so sagen donald
ist quasi der präsident der herzen der
republikaner und alle finden das super
wasser macht ich würde sagen einstimmig
kann man das wirklich bei beiden nicht
sagen also in beiden parteien demokraten
und republikaner gibt es wirklich ganz
viele unterschiedliche meinungen und
strömungen auch und beispielsweise bei
den demokraten mit denen wollen wir
vielleicht mal kurz anfangen da war es
ja wirklich der fall das einfach viele
junge leute auch wirklich unzufrieden
waren mit dabei
die haben gesagt er ist mir zu alt der
repräsentiert mich nicht und außerdem
ist mir die politik auch nicht
progressiv genug aber am ende des tages
haben sie sich geschlossen hinter ihn
gestellt weil natürlich das größte ziel
der demokraten ist man muss es ja
einfach mal so sagen dass die
republikaner nicht mehr an der macht
sind und umgekehrt ganz genauso und bei
den republikanern gibt es schon auch
wirklich also ganz viele trump fans also
die finden tatsächlich diese dieses jahr
recht spezielle art jaja hat also
wirklich sehr laut und kein blatt vor
den mund das finden die gut aber es gab
auch immer wieder republikanerinnen die
sich innerhalb der partei also auch von
ihm distanziert haben es gab auch eine
wirkliche kampagne von republikanern die
gesagt haben den kann man nicht mehr
wählen
das geht nicht mehr kannst du das noch
mal kurz umreißen was da passiert ist
da gibt es verschiedene kampagnen ich
finde eigentlich immer mit am
spannendsten des linken project was
wirklich ganz ganz viel jetzt während
der wahlkampfzeit also werbung gegen
president sharp gemacht hat und das sind
also ehemalige republikanerinnen und
unter anderem ist dass der mann von der
ehemaligen
sprecherin beraterin fans von kilian
conway und das ist also ein ehepaar was
komplett gespalten ist er der sich jetzt
also quasi gegen shanti republikaner
gewarnt hat und sie die nach wie vor
also wirklich dann in der glühende
anhängerin ist und man ist natürlich
muss ich wieder brechen auf das habe ich
so oft jetzt alles soll der berg ist
präsident tritt vor die presse und wir
sind gespannt was er sagt da sehen wir
ihnen r kommt jetzt auf die bühne
wir hören die usa usa rufen dass das
relativ üblich in den vereinigten
staaten und in wenigen sekunden wird er
dann wahrscheinlich vor das pult treten
es geht los
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist frei
das im franchise werken prozent vor
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am 1
masterplan zum rhein gebracht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fragen seien
[Applaus]
[Musik]
soweit also das statement von
us-präsident donald trump und seinem
vize präsidenten sorry falsche kamera
mike pence und er hat das getan was
viele erwartet haben noch vor dem
offiziellen wahlergebnis und dem ende
der auszählungen hat sich sonne jump
selber zum wahlsieger erklärt er sagt
immo zum dessous sofort zu dem marken
public also dass ein betrug an der
amerikanischen öffentlichkeit den dürfte
den demokraten vor we did we visited und
er hat versucht das ganze damit zu
begründen dass sie in den staaten wo
noch ausgezählt wird mit großem
vorsprung schon vor den demokraten und
von beiden liegen würden dass das quasi
unmöglich wäre dass er sie noch einholt
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe hat
er quasi dafür plädiert dass man jetzt
aufhört zu zählen weil er hat gesagt man
möchte nicht dass sie quasi noch
wählerstimmen irgendwo finden würden
also auch da wieder versucht er nahe zu
legen
die demokraten würden einen wahlbetrug
planen oder durchführen und ich bin
jetzt nochmal mit professor christian
lang hat von der fau berlin verbunden
hoffentlich diesmal mit ein bisschen
weniger tonproblemen professor sammert
das wird sicher lange habe den laptop
noch mal neu gestaltet wundervoll vielen
dank dafür
also sie haben gerade wahrscheinlich
mitverfolgt er hat gesagt deine kunden
twins oder sad sad ist also donald trump
das ein statement und er hat sich zum
wahlsieger erklärt mit dem verweis
darauf er würde ja überall so weit
führen das könnte man nicht mehr
aufholen ist das ein statement was man
so faktisch geltend lassen kann
ja also eher verlässt damit zumindest
den boden des wahlrechts in den usa dass
es in den einzelstaaten festgeschrieben
und der präsident kann ich sagen wann
aufgehört zu zählen sondern das ist in
gesetzen festgelegt es ist aber spannend
zu sehen er liegt ja eigentlich momentan
ganz gut
er hat florida gewonnen hat texas
gewonnen und er führt in den wichtigen
bittelbronn states aber wir sehen
momentan das sind in georgia north
carolina und auch ein bisschen in
wisconsin die marge kleiner wird mit dem
auszählen der briefwahlunterlagen und
das war etwas was zu erwarten war weil
in diesen briefwahlunterlagen
überwiegend demokraten eben abgestimmt
haben
und das scheint ihm jetzt ordentlich
angst zu machen dass dieser unterschied
noch so klein wird das eventuell beiden
ein paar dieser staaten noch umdrehen
kann
es ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich aber es
ist möglich und sich jetzt hinstellen
und sagen wir werden von den supreme
court gehen und das auszählen stoppen
lassen ist ein ganz schlechter
politischer zu glaube ich und entweder
haben die daten vorliegen die in sorgen
machen
oder er spielt wie er einfach nur selbst
inszenierung geht das denn überhaupt so
zügig quasi kann er per eilantrag jetzt
sagen ich rufe und beim support an jetzt
und sage einen antrag der wahl
auszählung stoppen
nein man muss ja gucken was ist in den
einzelstaaten gesetz und das ist genau
festgeschrieben ab wann die
briefwahlunterlagen da sein müssen
müssen sie am wahltag schon eingegangen
sein oder muss es dem poststempel geben
das ist leider nicht einheitlich
geregelt in den usa und von bundesstaat
zu bundesstaat unterschiedlich hier
sollte man vielleicht auch mal
reformieren und das vereinheitlichen
aber das sind gesetze in den
einzelstaaten das ist geltendes
wahlrecht und da kann sich der präsident
nicht darüber hinwegsetzen und ich sehe
auch keine supreme court entscheidung
die einfach geltendes wahlrecht in den
bundesstaaten überschreitet oder
aussetzt das heißt das ganze ist ein
manöver auf zeit oder ein verwirrung
manöver wie würden sie das einschätzen
das ist bei trump manchmal sehr schwer
zu sagen was seine motivation ist er hat
jetzt wieder einen guten presseauftritt
gehabt er hat sich als sieger
präsentiert obwohl das wahlergebnis noch
nicht feststeht er hat grund zum
optimismus das will ja auch keiner
nehmen er hat viel besser abgeschnitten
als viele experten dass vorher vermutet
haben aber er sollte sich jetzt auch an
die spielregeln halten und noch abwarten
weil wir in den usa momentan im zuge der
kurve pandemie eben einige änderungen
gesehen haben und da sollte man auch den
einzelnen staaten das recht geben die
stimmen so auszuzählen wie es die
rechtslage vorgibt hätte ich hier mal
kurz in unseren stream gucke dann gibt
es einen kommentar von jemandem der
schon in seinem user nehmen quasi
drinstehen hat dass er war es gegen
trump hat und meint trump weiß dass er
verloren hat er hat gerade angekündigt
dass er einen rechtsstreit führen
um zu gewinnen ist denn das jetzt so ich
komme hier quasi kann man das so stehen
lassen
das scheint mir nicht ganz korrekt zu
sein so so stark würde ich das auch
nicht nicht sagen ich glaube auch nicht
dass es schon jetzt verlässliche daten
gibt dass wir wirklich noch verlieren
sollte also momentan hat er genau so
gute chancen wie joe biden noch zum
präsidenten gewählt zu werden
es sind noch 45 staaten offen und daran
hängt ist wer gewinnt aber dass er jetzt
schon so früh wirklich in die offensive
geht und die legitimität des
wahlergebnis in frage stellt das ist
schon ein bisschen erstaunlich da ich
hab mir nochmal einen kommentar
professor lambert er geht in meine
richtung was mir vorgeworfen dass wäre
unverschämt wenn man noch mal auf dem
studium kommt auf den laptop geht drum
pictures als zig fach als rassisten
darzustellen als fakt absolut unzumutbar
und ich bin nicht mal für jump ich habe
ihn nicht als rassisten bezeichnet ich
habe gesagt er hat sich rassistisch
geäußert was in der regel aber dann doch
deckungsgleich ist können sie da dem
user zur seite springen oder können sie
mir zur seite springen professor lammert
na ja man sieht eindeutig wie er sich
benimmt kontext der blätter bewegung
geäußert hat wir hier artikuliert hat
nicht nur gegenüber afroamerikanern am
anfang 2016 auch gegenüber mexikanern
die er fast schon unter generalverdacht
gestellt hat er spielt hier mit
rassistischen konnotation erweist dass
er damit wähler mobilisieren kann
rassismus ist ein tiefes
gesellschaftliches problem und er nutzt
das für seine politische mobilisierung
macht ihnen das selber zum rassisten ich
weiß es nicht es gibt untersuchungen
dass er als business man als
geschäftsmann auch diskriminierende
einstellungspolitik betrieben hat in
seinem unternehmen da kann man auch ein
muster erkennen ob er jetzt wirklich in
rassistisch spielt dann eigentlich keine
rolle er bedient diese rassistischen
ressentiments um seine wählerschaft zu
mobilisieren
abschließende frage noch mal ansieht
professor lammert donald trump hat eine
wahlmanipulation ja angemahnt die
zwischen beziehungsweise gerade schon
gesagt die wahl wäre manipuliert worden
dass es sofort to the american public
health wortwörtlich gesagt könnte es ein
vorwärts ein vorwand sein um selbst
einer manipulation herbeizuführen
nein ich glaube man man gibt da den
kandidaten auch zu viel macht dazu ist
das amerikanische wahlsystem gar nicht
in der lage das man von der spitze ist
aus manipulieren kann man kann höchstens
mal begrenzt in einigen wahlkreisen
versuchen was zu erreichen
aber auch das ist ein großer aufwand und
ein großes risiko
das amerikanische wahlsystem ist sehr
fragmentiert chaotisch organisiert
deswegen brauchen manche staaten jetzt
auch länger gerade unter diesen
bedingungen und das jetzt als ausrede zu
benutzen das man aufhören sollte zu
zählen und das argument hatte er
deutlich gemacht es darf nicht gezählt
werden wenn dieser wahltag zu ende ist
das entspricht keinerlei rechtsgrundlage
dieses argument und ich kann mir auch
nicht vorstellen selbst wenn ihr viele
bundesrichter anrufen konnte unter
seiner amtszeit ist die gerichte ihm in
dieser argumentation folgen wären wenn
sie das tun hat die amerikanische
demokratie ein großes problem
professor christian hat vielen dank dass
sie heute morgen uns mit rat und tat und
fakten zur seite gestanden haben dass er
das einmal eingeschätzt haben und danke
dass sie das problem fixen konnten
das ist halt einfach so wenn man mit
kleinen mitteln produziert ich bedanke
mich und wünschen noch einen schönen tag
so wir schauen jetzt nochmal auf die
aktuellen zahlen die wir jetzt für sie
und ich habe nicht guckt noch mal hier
auf den anderen monitor da ist er also
bei uns geht es nach wie vor in der
auszählung 213 zu 220 213 für donald
trump 220 joe biden aber wir haben es ja
gerade schon gesehen und gehört es
laufen noch auszählungen die können wir
auch sehen hier auf dieser karte
ich kann euch nur raten wenn ihr das im
blick behalten wollte leidet unsere app
unter da kriegt er alle zahlen daten und
fakten von uns gesichert geliefert und
wir können hier sehen das rote hier ist
sind die bundesstaaten die wahlmänner
für donald trump schicken werden das
blaue sind die bundesstaaten die
wahlmänner und wahlfrauen
für joe biden in die wahl im elektro
college schicken werden im dezember und
das gelbe sind die noch nicht
ausgezählten bundesstaaten und das ist
ganz spannend wenn man jetzt mal hier
auf die staaten rauf trägt zb nevada das
war ganz weit im westen da ist der
ausstellungsstand gerade 78 prozent hier
kann man es ganz gut sehen und dort
führt joe biden mit 50 kommen
hierzu 47,7 prozent werden wir mal
zurück gehen nächstes arizona dort ist
zu 82 prozent nach unseren informationen
ausgezählt worden
dort wird ebenfalls joe biden mit 51,8
prozent aber ihr seht schon wie knapp
das ganze ist dann gehen wir mal weiter
hier ganz oben in den norden das
wisconsin auszählungsstand 81% und dort
führt donald trump mit 104 52,1 prozent
47,1 prozent für die beiden dass nach
diesem stand würde wisconsin an die
republikaner gehen
wir gucken auf den nächsten start gleich
nebenan das ist michigan
auszählungsstand noch nicht soweit 68
prozent das heißt da fehlt noch ein
knappes drittel
dort führt ebenfalls donald trump
relativ deutlich muss man sagen das
heißt da ist die frage ob sich da noch
was tun kann aber das ist eben einmal
das problem wenn diese ein drittel noch
nicht ausgezählten wählerstimmen alles
briefwahlunterlagen sind dann kann das
noch dauern und wenn das stimmt was wir
jetzt immer prophezeit oder vorher
gesagt wurde dass briefwähler vor allen
demokratisch wählen könnte sich das
blatt natürlich noch wenden
dann schauen wir weiter ein staat weiter
im westen ist nichtigen hatten wir
gerade schon da habe ich mich wohl grad
knapp verpflegt wisconsin auszählung
statt 81 prozent hier führt auch donald
trump dann wenn wir jetzt mal hier in
den osten gehen
oben nordosten das ist mein
auszählungsstand auch er 67 prozent ein
drittel fehlt also auch noch dort führt
relativ deutlich gerade joe biden mit
54,5 prozent
und wir gehen auch mal weiter was haben
wir noch übrig wir haben hier einmal
nach north carolina das ist so gut wie
gelaufen das rennen 95 prozent dort hat
donald trump mit 50,1 prozent gewonnen
gegen 48,7 also auch ein knappes rennen
und dann haben wir hier noch georgia
auch dort ist das rennen so gut wie
gelaufen 91% ausgezählt donald trump hat
dort mit 50,6 prozent gewonnen und ich
glaube dann haben wir fast alle staaten
noch kleiner hatten wir gerade schon ja
ich glaube dann haben wir einmal alle
noch offenen staaten durch maine hatten
wir auch schon und ich glaube unten
genau unten gibt es nach alaska
die haben noch gar nicht ausgezählt da
gibt es noch 0,0 prozent aber alaska
hat auch nicht so viele wahlmänner und
wahlfrauen so also es bleibt weiterhin
spannend so wie es ja doch prophezeit
wurde es gibt keinen eindeutigen sieg
von donald trump was muss man sagen dann
auch schon wieder etwas ungewöhnlich ist
denn bislang galt fast die regel dass
der amtierende präsident eine zweite
amtszeit in der regel in der tasche hat
da gab es immer ein vorteil für den
amtierenden präsidenten das ist dieses
mal nicht der fall ist bleibt ein
spannendes kopf-an-kopf-rennen donald
trump hat sich aber gerade vor der
presse geäußert und hat sich selbst zum
wahlsieger erklärt hat den demokraten
wahlbetrug vorgeworfen und angekündigt
er werde die wahl stoppen wollen also
die auszählung weiter stoppen lassen
wollen vor dem supreme court das ganze
haben wir gerade gehört von professor
lammert politik professor an der fu
berlin ist in keinem gesetz der usa
vorgesehen und auch daher nicht legal dh
der tag wird weiter spannend verlaufen
ich bedanke mich jetzt bei euch fürs zu
sehen für die kommentare ich bedanke
mich auch für die netten kommentare wir
haben hier viel lob bekommen
von annina von abe auf youtube von nico
der addison unsere reporterin sehr
sympathisch fand und ich bitte um
verständnis und entschuldigung dass es
hier ein bisschen gewackelt und
geruckelt hat das liegt einerseits daran
eben dass wir mit sparsamen mitteln
produzieren weil die gebühren sind auch
nicht unendlich und wir versuchen das
trotzdem hier für euch möglich zu machen
dass wir hier einen gemeinsamen
austausch haben aber dann nichts halt
manchmal auch daran dass die reporterin
ganz allein da draußen unterwegs ist und
nicht mit kamerateam und von daher kann
das manchmal ein bisschen schwierig
werden aber das gehört zum leben dazu
und ist glaube ich auch menschlich so
wir machen den stream für jetzt erst mal
dicht wir werden uns heute abend wieder
melden ist sei denn in der zwischenzeit
passiert irgendwie was ganz bahnbrechend
ist dann sind wir natürlich auch wieder
für euch da gibt uns ein abo auf den
entsprechenden kanäle nach denen gerade
unterwegs seid dann kriegt ihr auf jeden
fall auch einen alarm auf youtube freuen
wir uns nicht locker aktiviert oder wenn
ihr euch die zdf- heute- app auf ihr
mobiles endgerät leidet dann gibt es
auch immer eine mitteilung wenn er sie
erlaubt wenn wir live gehen in diesem
sinne sei jetzt aber erstmal das war's
wir warten weiter was passiert bis
später und tschüss